how long we've known each other chin I
ever break a promise to you I will put
you in the driver's seat at Lamar you
just shut your mouth and let me do my
thing
all right morning Shelby Warren Molly
appeals I'll go to help
and that's it folks Ferrari wins to 24
hours of LaVon for the fifth consecutive
year
mr. Ford very has a message for you sir
What did he say he said for it makes
ugly little cars and ugly factories and
God you fat sir we're gonna bury Ferrari
at LeMond so the great cowl Shelby is
gonna build a car to beat Ferrari with a
fault correct and how long did you tell
them you needed two or three hundred
years 90 days Paul hates guys like us
because we're different we heard he's
difficult to ken no no Ken's a puppy dog
[Music]
it's Soho there's a problem the computer
will find out you get some scotch tape
and a ball of wool what are they doing
making your car faster
and miles it's not fourth man we're on
the verge of something and now you tell
me that I can't have the best man in the
world behind the wheel give me one
reason why I don't fire everyone
starting this you well sir the lighter
work faster and that don't work we're
nastier
go ahead go go to war I risk I thought
the whole point was to win the damned
race
[Applause]
if this were a beauty pageant
we just lost looks aren't everything
you